[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis bekommen und guten abend unter
anderem alles wichtige vom wintersport
gleich von norbert lehmann
schauen wir auf die großen themen in
dieser sendung
ein bisschen lockerung wagen sachsen
öffnet unter anderem sein größtes
skigebiet und belohnt sich damit für
relativ niedrige corona zahlen
vorbereitung zum einmarsch russland
verlegt noch mehr militär an die
ukrainische grenze und beobachter sehen
die kriegsgefahr steigen
und in guter form für peek gehen mit
einem zweiten platz fährt die deutsche
biathlon männer staffel drei wochen vor
olympia ihr erstes top resultat der
saison ein
durch micon steigen die korona zahlen in
deutschland immer weiter fast täglich
gibt es neue höchstwerte lange war
sachsen corona hotspot im moment jedoch
steht das bundesland vergleichsweise gut
da während die sieben tage incidence
bundesweit mittlerweile bei
497,1 liegt ist sie in sachsen bei
228,7 ein grund der niedrige anteil der
nikon variante bundesweit dominiert
omikron das infektionsgeschehen da liegt
der anteil bei rund 73 prozent in
sachsen nur bei rund 26 prozent und das
hat positive folgen zumindest noch wie
stefan kech zeigt der schnee liegt schon
seit wochen im erzgebirge doch erst
jetzt dürfen sie auch darauf rodeln und
wedeln bis gestern war alles dicht
sachsen hatte bundesweit die schärfsten
regeln doch nun öffnet sachsen wieder
ich glaube genau jetzt muss das signal
kommen die politik ist verlässlich
niedrige zahlen als es muss geöffnet
werden aber wir appellieren weiter lasst
euch im denn überall der euphorie
schwebt immer ein großes wenn wenn die
zahlen unten bleiben denn wenn nicht
kann es auch ganz schnell wieder vorbei
sein mit der freude eine freude die
dresdner wird thomas widmann ohnehin
nicht teilt denn es sind keine touristen
in dresden und damit auch kaum gäste und
die nun geltenden zweig plus regeln
seien sowieso eher verschärfung als
lockerung
22 uhr heißt noch mal zwei stunden mehr
verlustgeschäft zu betreiben also für
uns bringen dass im moment nichts jetzt
hat er beschlossen geschlossen zu lassen
und abzuwarten ob nicht bald alles
wieder zurückgenommen wird auch der
intendant der dresdner semperoper kann
sich nur zu verhaltener freude
durchringen zu oft in den letzten beiden
jahren musste die kultur in sachsen als
erstes schließen
das substanzverlust der da eintritt wenn
wir nicht spielen sowohl für unser
publikum als auch für uns selber ist
einfach groß und wir können hier nicht
einfach nur in diesem stop go verfahren
weiter machen wir müssen spielen wir
müssen da sein dasein wollen sie auch in
den wintersportorten und vor allem
wollen sie da bleiben für die
wirtschaftlich angeschlagene tourismus
branche zählt nun jeder offene tag
notfall medizinerinnen und mediziner
fordern bessere corona daten aus den
krankenhäusern
es brauche endlich ein monitoring das
krone infizierte in allen bereichen
erfasst also nicht nur die auf den
intensivstationen die hospitalisierung
incidents also die krankenhaus
einlieferung in einer woche pro 100.000
einwohner ist aktuell relativ stabil
gestern lag sie laut rp bei 3,23 der
wert wird wegen nachmeldungen aber noch
steigen wie es aktuell in den
notaufnahmen aussieht hat sich eva
schiller in stuttgart angeschaut sie
müssen in sekundenschnelle entscheiden
notfallpatientin isolieren dabei
wertvolle zeit verlieren oder nicht
es ist unklar ob die frau mit corona
infiziert ist sie gehen auf nummer
sicher leben retten und gleichzeitig die
infektionsgefahr in schach halten das
ist akkordarbeit und als erstes glied in
der klinik kette fühlen sich notfall
pfleger wie simon besser manchmal
übersehen zu wenig geschätzt
beschreiben aber es ist schon sehr an
den nerven und an den kräften dass man
einfach wären einfach gerecht wird und
trotzdem da ist ein aufatmen ein
luftholen nach der vierten welle die
zahl der koma patientin geht zurück
gleichzeitig schnellen die
neuinfektionen in rekordhöhen aber der
blick ins ausland macht mut und
frankreich dass ein stück weit früher
betroffen war hält das nicht schritt die
tests gehen hoch die auch
spezialisierungen steigen dass wir nur
leicht die hoffnung dass die band eine
wand der positiven testergebnisse ist
und die welle in den krankenhäusern
hoffentlich etwas abgeflacht werden kann
auf der korona station sind nur 12 von
32 betten belegt mittlerweile sind fast
alle mit omikron infiziert es kommen
mehr im durch brüche meist vor erkrankte
patienten wie leonie charme bier sie hat
eine transplantierte niere die impfung
und ein neues corona medikament
verhindern bislang den schweren verlauf
ich bin froh dass ich die impfung habe
und ich habe davor schon gewusst dass es
behandlungsmethoden für risikopatienten
gibt und eben auch für erfahrungen
gehört dass es dann ganz gut verlaufen
ist dass ich mich damit bisschen
beruhigen konnte die omikron variante
überwiegend draußen halten ambulant in
den griff bekommen darauf hoffen sie
hier und dass ich nicht zu viel
klinikpersonal gleichzeitig infiziert
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsschutzes haldenwang
sieht bei den corona demos eine neue
szene von staatsfeinden diese hätten
keine gemeinsame ideologie sondern
würden den rechtsstaat als solchen und
dessen repräsentanten grundlegend
ablehnen so haldenwang in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
in hamburg haben sich trotz verbots
wieder mehrere tausend gegner der korona
maßnahmen versammelt die polizei löste
die du musst auf erstmals kann es in der
hansestadt zu einer größeren
gegenveranstaltung fast 3.000 menschen
gingen gegen korona leugner und
verschwörungs ideologen auf die straße
mehr als ursprünglich angemeldet waren
dazu aufgerufen hatte ein breites
bündnis gegen rechts
es war ja eine diplomatische offensive
vergangene woche mit den usa der nato
bei der osze gab es gespräche mit
russland das ziel die eskalation in der
ukraine krise aber eine wirkliche
annäherung gab es nicht im gegenteil
am montag reist daher
bundesaußenminister in bernburg in die
ukraine und nach russland thomas
gonschior über die neuen spannungen
moskau macht mobil verlegt truppen und
panzer richtung ukraine mehr und mehr
und zeigt das gerne der welt die ist
mehr und mehr beunruhigt pentagon und
weißes haus sagen gestern spätabends
russland bereitet ein anlass für einen
angriff vor wir haben informationen dass
russland kräfte in stellung gebracht hat
für eine false flag operation im osten
der ukraine
phones fleck unter falscher flagge die
operation lief in den separatisten
gebieten das prinzip russische agenten
greifen pro-russische stellungen wie
diese an ihre unterstützer also nach
außen ließe sich das als ukrainischen
angriff darstellen vorwand für moskau
das land anzugreifen geschehen könnte
das ab sofort so washington russland
dementiert heute per facebook wie üblich
gibt es keine beweise teilt die
botschaft in washington mit die
unablässigen anschuldigungen gegen uns
von den usa opfern politik oder medien
sind unbegründet russland ist gegen den
krieg gleichwohl gab es bereits einen
angriff einen via internet die webseiten
der ukrainischen regierung gestern
lahmgelegt das außen das
katastrophenschutzministerium online
nicht erreichbar das waren russische
hacker das militär in kiew sagt dass
sich da sicher die taktik immer die
stabilisierung dann starten sie eine
aktion
deeskalation sollten diese woche
gespräche mit russland bringen greifbare
ergebnisse fehlanzeige stattdessen eine
alarmierende einschätzung litauens die
gefahr eines kriegs in europa ist so
groß wie seit 1945 nicht mehr moskau
macht mobil machen die russen ernst der
westen hofft noch dass sie doch kein
feuer entzünden wollen
zurück nach deutschland
der bundesarbeitsminister will das
strafrecht verschärfen um die wahlen von
betriebsräten zu erleichtern die
behinderung von betriebsrats gründungen
durch arbeitgeber solle künftig von der
justiz von amts wegen auch ohne
vorliegende anzeige als straftat
verfolgt werden so heil
behinderung ist zwar jetzt schon
verboten kann aber nur verfolgt werden
wenn etwa arbeitnehmervertreter oder
gewerkschaften dass auch anzeigen
innerparteilich zerstritten führende
oppositionsrolle im bundestag verloren
für die afg läuft es derzeit nicht rund
bei einem treffen der fraktionsspitze in
berlin versuchte sie sich fürs neue jahr
aufzustellen dabei beschloss sie auch
künftig noch enger mit der rechten
österreichischen fpl zusammenzuarbeiten
nicole diekmann über das treffen
fdp fraktions vorstandsklausur tag zwei
freundliche gesichter bei der
fraktionsspitze bei anderen aber weniger
begeisterung beim anblick der
zugelassenen presse
die stimmung in der afg war schon besser
die zeiten für die afg waren es auch bei
allen fünf landtagswahlen vergangenes
jahr stimmenverluste ebenso bei der
bundestagswahl die bedeutungsvolle rolle
als oppositionsführerin dahin von
selbstkritik trotzdem keine spur unsere
politischen gegner versuchen alles was
wir sagen in den bereich des unsagbaren
zu verschieben ich war also jegliche
kritik an der regierungspolitik in bezug
auf corona in bezug auf klima in bezug
auf diese spaltung der gesellschaft wird
als etwas definiert was gar nicht geht
und das hat im vorjahr war leider etwas
verlangen fundamental opposition auch
gegen die korona maßnahmen im parlament
seit donnerstag gilt dort zweig plus
beschlossen mit den stimmen aller
fraktionen außer denen der afg einer
ihrer abgeordneten ungeimpft aber
getestet durfte an einer ausschuss
sitzung nicht teilnehmen die
fraktionsspitze wittert eine
verschwörung
sowas habe ich wirklich noch nie erlebt
und hier muss man sich wirklich fragen
ob es hier wirklich noch um corona geht
oder um eine machtdemonstration
gegenüber der opposition heute also
strategie suche und besuch von der fpö
den österreichischen rechtspopulisten
werden kontakte zur rechtsradikalen
nachgesagt ebenso wie der afd die
entscheidung über deren gesamte
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
wird für märz erwartet die zeiten für
die partei könnten noch schwieriger
werden
auch die linke hat nach der
bundestagswahl redebedarf und will sich
nach dem starken stimmenverlust neu
ausrichten vor allem in der sozial- und
klimapolitik ein entsprechendes
strategiepapier diskutierte die partei
bei ihrem digitalen jahresauftakt nach
den vorstellungen der linken spitze soll
deutschland bereits 20 35 klimaneutral
sein und damit zehn jahre früher als von
der bundesregierung angepeilt die
klimapolitik der ampel würde zu einer
sozialen schieflage führen
nach afghanistan seit der machtübernahme
der taliban ist das land im freien fall
es droht eine humanitäre katastrophe
um den menschen vor ort helfen zu können
sind laut vereinten nationen rund 4,4
milliarden euro nötig es mangelt an
allem vor allem an essen und die hälfte
der bevölkerung leidet unter akutem
hunger zehntausenden kindern droht der
hungertod über die not in afghanistan
katrin eigendorf
es sind drei grad minus in kabul schnee
und kälte haben die stadt in eine
weitere krise gestürzt nicht nur die
lebensmittel sind knapp auch holz zum
heizen fehlt in vielen familien kanada
versucht den hof seines leben hauses das
er vor acht jahren selbst gebaut hat
trocken zu halten seine beiden kleinen
kinder haben nicht einmal feste schuhe
als es letztens geschneit hat kam das
wasser durch die decke unser nachbar hat
es gesehen und uns ein bisschen geld
geliehen für plastik um die fenster
abzudecken das ist unsere lage an einem
tag haben wir etwas zu essen am nächsten
tag nicht was sie tun es gibt keine
lösung
fast ein halbes jahr sind die taliban an
der macht mit jedem tag den sie das land
kontrollieren wächst die not die
wirtschaft fast vollkommen kollabiert
der staat ohne finanzen
in kabul stehen hunderte in der schlange
der lebensmittelverteilung des world
food programm fast alle internationalen
hilfsorganisationen haben ihre mittel
erhöht und doch reicht es nicht
der mangel an essen und der hunger ist
beängstigend wir hatten familien in
kabul und auch in einigen provinzen die
sind gestorben weil sie über wochen
hunger litten
als tagelöhner hat kanada bislang waren
transportiert schon vor der
machtübernahme der taliban waren sie arm
jetzt müssen sie sich immer öfter
entscheiden lebensmittel oder holz
hungern oder frieren
afghanistan drohe in diesem winter von
einer lawine von hunger und elend
überrollt zu werden warnen
hilfsorganisationen
nur mit internationaler unterstützung
wird das land davor bewahrt werden
können
und sie können den menschen in
afghanistan mit einer spende helfen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
dafür ein konto eingerichtet die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das
stichwort zdf nothilfe afghanistan
weitere infos gibt es im internet auf
spenden punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 8 190
der ausbruch eines vulkans im
pazifikstaat tonga hält dort die
menschen in atem seit gestern ist der
vulkan auf einer unbewohnten insel aktiv
eine asche und gas wolke stieg etwa 20
kilometern die luft die schwersten
erschütterungen löste einen tsunami aus
der auf die hauptinsel von tonga zu
heute von einer gut ein meter hohen
welle ist die rede die zahlreiche häuser
überschwemmt haben soll berichte über
verletzte gibt es nicht
und wir kommen jetzt zum wintersport zu
norbert denn endlich geht ja was bei der
deutschen wird warnt stark die ist beim
weltcup in ruhpolding im dritten anlauf
in diesem winter das erste mal aufs
podest gelaufen das deutsche männer
quartett erkämpfte sich hinter russland
und vor belarus nach starker aufholjagd
den zweiten platz dieser podestplatz
balsam für die seele und auch ein
fingerzeig in richtung olympia in vier
wochen steht das olympische staffel
rennen auf dem programm jeder sein ding
macht dann sind wir durchaus in der lage
da mitzuspielen
beim letzten wechsel deutschland zum
ersten mal unter den top 3 an der spitze
russland dahinter belarus der showdown
dann beim letzten schießen schlussläufer
philipp nawrath im duell mit smolski aus
belarus nach rat abgezockt fünf treffer
die russen können ihren vorsprung bis
ins ziel retten gewinnen zum ersten mal
in diesem winter das deutsche quartett
wirtz weiter auf rang drei belarus und
es gab noch weiter dort weitere deutsche
erfolge heute im wintersport vor allem
im rodeln für die 311 ludwig langenhan
noch ein dreifachtriumph in oberhof ein
bild das sie auch gerne bei den
olympischen spielen abgeben würden die
deutschen rodler besetzen das komplette
weltcup podium auf seiner heimbahn ist
johannes ludwig der deutlich schnellste
verbessert sogar den bahnrekord sein
fünfter saisonsieg beschert ihm
vorzeitig den ersten gesamtweltcupsieg
karl geiger sich hat mit seinem zweiten
sprung den zweiten platz im team
wettkampf von zakopane polen damit
überholen er und seine kollegen severin
freund stephan leyhe und markus
eisenbichler noch die japaner
unangefochtener sieger aber das
slowenische team
ihrer weihe wird zweite in der weltcup
abfahrt von zauchensee österreich nur
eine zehntelsekunde trend weiter von der
siegerin lara gut behrami aus der
schweiz rechtzeitig vor den spielen von
peking tank die wm-zweite damit einen
guten schuss selbstbewusstsein
bundesliga tabellenführer münchen hat
seinen sechs-punkte-vorsprung
verteidigt durch den sieg gegen köln
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des 19
spieltags köln bayern 0 zu vier union
schlägt hoffenheim 2 2 1 stuttgart
unterliegt leipzig mit 0 2 mainz bz
bochum mit 1 0 wolfsburg härter null zu
null das abendspiel gladbach leverkusen
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr und
bereits gestern dortmund 5 2 1 sieg
gegen freiburg die tabelle oben
unverändert münchen 1 dortmund 2
hoffenheim 3 union jetzt auf platz vier
freiburg fünfter die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit frankfurt und
ganz unten auch alles unverändert
augsburg bielefeld und schlusslicht wird
der
serbische tennis star novak djokovic
musste heute in melbourne wieder in ein
abschiebe hotel umziehen morgen soll ein
bundesgericht entscheiden ob er bei den
australian open am montag antreten kann
oder ob er das land verlassen muss
deutschlands handballer sind mit dem
erhofften erfolgserlebnis in die
europameisterschaft gestartet die dhb
auswahl gewann ihr erstes vorrundenspiel
gestern abend in bratislava nach großen
schwierigkeiten in der ersten halbzeit
gegen belarus mit 33 zu 29 und nahm
damit kurs auf die hauptrunde und
morgen das zweite gruppenspiel vor rund
ums spiel gegen österreich gefeiert
in washington freuen sich die menschen
über höchst seltenen besuch und zwar
über diesen gefährten gast schneeeulen
leben eigentlich überwiegend in der nähe
des polarkreises dass ich mal eine bis
in die amerikanische hauptstadt verwirrt
ist sehr selten und das begehrte foto
objekt scheint der trubel gar nicht zu
stören
sehr süß von schnee gibt es morgen bei
uns keine spur mehr zum wetter gleich
von esther lee das heute-journal können
sie heute um 22.45 sehen mit christian
sievers schön haben noch
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unserer satelliten
film vom heutigen tag zeigt uns viel
grau in grau hier in der mitte und nach
süden und auch im osten wurde dieser
nebel allmählich angeknabbert verzog
sich aber kaum die berge stechen hervor
da gab es viel sonnenschein oder auch im
südwesten scheint längere zeit die sonne
genauso wie nach norden hin aber dann
zog es auch hier etwas zu nachts gibt es
weiterhin viele wolken teilweise wieder
nebel und der bildet sich im süden
durchaus auch neue ganz im süden und
südwesten zeigen sich die sterne und im
norden da tröpfelt es etwas im süden
wird es eisig kalt bis -6 grad nach
norden hin bitten mit plus 3 grad
frostfrei morgen tagesverlauf weiterhin
dichte bewölkung und hier und da etwas
regen im süden deutschlands aber auch
sonnenschein die temperaturen dazu mit
maximal minus ein grad im vogtland und 8
grad an der nordsee die nächsten tage am
montag kommt von norden regen und schnee
auf stauen sich dann durchaus in den
bergen zwei bis neun grad die
höchstwerte und vor allem am dienstag
wird es dann etwas trockener sein ein
schöner abend